So, I just got home from the Moth
performing at the Moth last night. It
was my wow
my 169th performance at the Moth. I
think about 131 story slams and 39 grand
slams and actually some mainstage shows.
A whole bunch is the point. And yet,
despite all of those performances, I
learned something important last night.
On the way to the moth, I put my story
together in the car, which is not
something you should really do, but I
will occasionally do. I knew what my
story was. Like, I sort of know what
happened and I knew what my beginning
and ending were, but I didn't really
have any structure. I hadn't spoken it
out loud. I hadn't put words to it. So,
I got in the car. I've got a 2-hour
drive to Boston. I've got two friends
with me. Both of them attend Moths all
the time with me. And so, they're
they're good at giving me advice. And so
I sort of picked through the story once
and figured out what it would be. And
then I said it a couple more times, uh,
you know, honing some of the moments,
finding the right sentences, all of
those things. And then I got to the moth
and, uh, my name was chosen fourth. So I
told my story and during intermission
another storyteller who happened to be
attending who knows me and know who
knows that sometimes I will put a story
together in the car and then perform it
on stage which again is not the smartest
thing to do but something I occasionally
do. This storyteller asked my friend Ka
so I want to know is the story that Matt
told you in the car on the way to the
moth the same story that he just told on
the stage and Kaia said absolutely not.
And I was surprised by her answer, but
it only took me a second to realize she
was totally correct. The story I told in
the car was completely different than
what I had done on stage. In the car,
what I did was created structure. I
figured out what the scenes would be. I
knew what the goals of each scene would
be. I sort of developed some transitions
from scene to scene. But that was about
all I did in the car. I gave it words
the first time, but the words that I
gave it in the car were actually not the
same words I performed on stage. I found
new jokes to tell along the way. I
dropped information that I felt wasn't
necessary. I responded to the audience.
When they seemed to like something, I
added a little bit to it. And when they
seem not to respond to something, I
pulled back. Ka was completely right.
The story on stage really came to life
in a way it had not come to life in the
car. But what I did and what I tell
people all the time is I gave it
structure in which I could work. I don't
memorize stories. I remember them. I
remember what happened to me and I
create the structure so that when I'm on
stage, I can be flexible and I can
adjust and I can meet the needs of the
audience and I can meet the time limit
and all of those things. So structure,
it's everything. It is it is really the
framework in which we operate as
storytellers and performers. We need to
know what the goal of each scene is, how
we get from one to the other, what's the
chronological structure that we've
created, but ultimately once we have
that in place, we have the freedom to
adjust and create and respond in
meaningful ways. I won the slam that
night. It was my
60 moth story slam win of about 131
story slams. And so I did well. I did
well with structure, not with
memorization, not with the careful
choice of vocabulary, not with sentence
structure, but with an understanding
about what my story was, a framework in
which I could operate and then the
freedom to create, adjust, modify, be
myself so that I wasn't someone who was
reciting memorized words on stage, but
actually telling a story from my heart
and my mind with a little bit of
planning ahead. It's not the way I would
advise anyone to go and perform in front
of 500 people. It is not the way that
you should ever think about doing it.
This is one of those do as I say, not as
I do situations. But what you should be
thinking is structure first. Once you
understand the beginning and the end and
the scenes and the transitions and the
goals of each one of those scenes, once
you have that in place, the sentences
that you apply become your own. And when
they really are your own and not so
pre-planned that they feel like they're
memorized and performed, that is when
storytelling becomes alive. So Ka was
right. The story I told in the car was
very different than the story I told on
stage. And yet ultimately it was the
same story. So structure, structure
first, everything else second. Thanks
for watching. And if you're still
watching and you haven't clicked off yet
to the next video, good for you. Like
way to go. Like the video since you're
still here. Subscribe to the channel
because I'm going to make another video
and you're going to like that one, too.
And stick around. I really appreciate
you watching what I'm making.